what's going on guys you know Oscar
nominations came out this morning but
who gives a rat's ass about that it's
time for the third annual screen ease
the awards show that you know and love
today we're going to cover the awesomest
and lamest crap and entertainment from
calendar year 2014 let's start the
screen our first category is the strike
while the iron is cold award it goes to
the sequel they waited way too long to
make and so on we didn't even care about
the damn movies anymore
the nominees are Sin City to a dame to
kill for 300 rise of an empire Night at
the Museum three and the winner Dumb and
Dumber to they waited so long to make
this movie that Jeff Daniels is now a
bigger star than Jim Carrey Congrats
guys
next up is to stop making these award
the nominees are Hercules movies
universal monster flicks Schwarzenegger
flicks and the winner is trailer
trailers we don't need a 10-second
teaser that shows us nothing for a
trailer that will also show us nothing
just give it to us or don't you don't
need a trailer for a trailer honest
trailers though yeah those are pretty
good now it's time for the I still don't
know if it sucks or not award this goes
to the movie or TV show that we're still
not sure if it's good or not the
nominees are agents of shield Godzilla
homeland and the winner is interstellar
I've seen fanboys getting fist fights
over this movie but for my money jury's
still out
Congrats interstellar I have no idea if
you're good or not next up you guys it's
the best title for that Tom Cruise movie
award and nominees are all you need is
kill that's the name of the graphic
novel edge of tomorrow that's the name
of the movie one is released in theatres
lived I repeat that's the name of the
movie when I was released on iTunes geez
do you wanna confuse us anymore and the
winner is this name that we just came up
with Groundhog Day with aliens guns and
Bill Paxton awesome name I'd see the
hell out of that movie Congrats and now
it's time for the first annual movie
fights let them fight award it goes to
the best action
the nominees are John wick Captain
America the Winter Soldier Lucy
winner is the raid - you know what I
took the time to count every punch and
kick in the raid - you know how many
there were
47,000 978
prove me wrong I've got someone to do
them will someone do that
next up Oh this is a biggie the
mainstream movie that sounds like a
porno award the noms are the giver as
above so below the box goals under the
skin sex tape the nut job and the winner
is bears Disney's first nature
documentary slash internet fetish film
Congrats to the film bears and the
entire bear community Nick Mundy
Andy signor we salute you here's a
related award the sounds like a comic
book movie but isn't award the nominees
are whiplash URI Foxcatcher
November man and the winner is
Nightcrawler there was nothing x-men
related in the movie Nightcrawler I went
in there expectancy juggernaut
I got Rene Russo don't snooze and lose
on this award it's the that came out
this year award what the nominees are
the animated sequel for wizard of odds
what the Rosemary's Baby TV show with
Zoe Saldana that wasn't a thing it was
Arnold Schwarzenegger 'he's sabotage no
that that really and the winner is jason
reitman men women and children no that's
coming out this year that came out last
year what Adam Sandler was in it up
Congrats men women and children this is
probably the only award you're gonna get
this award it's the most Awkward
celebrity and powder award the nominees
are this kind of racist anchorman who
did not know who Sam Jackson was did you
get a lot of reaction that Superbowl
commercial
what's over bow commercial I give you a
plate you're you're as crazy as the
people on Twitter right
scribblers this anchorman who lied about
seeing the skeleton twins do you have
advice for going nude um you do it in
the film mr. Nottoli not that Michelle
not this movie that's a different movie
oh you're not nude in this film you're
Newton another one the underage girl
James Franco sent pervy instagrams to
and the winner is me and Shia LeBouf why
are we in this weird weird situation I'm
still recovering from that awkward
surreal experience and Shia no I'm sorry
ah here's one for the kids dumbest name
and a dystopian why a franchise the
nominees are PETA from The Hunger Games
zart from the Maze Runner
Haymitch Abernathy also from The Hunger
Games
and the winner is four from divergent
pretty sure they're just picking random
words at this point I look forward to
the next why franchise and its hero milk
board seven stick Oh
this next war takes me all the way back
to 2013 it's the let's reference
Breaking Bad because we can award it
goes to the opening credits of Godzilla
where Bryan Cranston's name appears on
screen with Walter White
no kidding nothing like taking the
audience out of the reality of your film
right up top next up is the
unintentional comedy award which goes to
the most unintentionally funny
performance of the year the nominees are
Jamie Foxx doing Jim Carrey's Riddler in
the amazing spider-man - Spidey how was
your morning beast this really weird
waiter in The Fault in Our Stars I'm
tasting the stops Mark Wahlberg as a
Texan and transformers 4 I'm an inventor
this could be a game changer for me and
the winner is John Travolta at the
Oscars please welcome the wickedly
talented one and only Adele does e good
one Travolta as always before we go we'd
like to take a moment to say goodbye to
the people and things that we lost an
entertainer
this year
your movies suck so bad they were
you sound real bad
down don't skirt
it's
ball
we all
your movie sucks so bad
done
you sound real bad by sometime
don't skirt
it's
fall we all want
so wrap another screen ease in the books
Hey
what'd we leave out and if you could
come up with any screen e category what
would it be
leave us an answer in the comments
section below best answer but we're
gonna send you screen junkies t-shirt I
want to thank you guys for watching by
the way our fans are awesome you all
deserve screenings thanks for watching
I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye
bye the number one thing I noticed is
that anytime Michael Douglas says the
name Scott I think of Liberace and
behind the candelabra Scott Skye I need
you say yes Scott